update vom brückenbau in rußbach in
salzburg die arbeiten gehen zügig voran
also ich hatte mich jetzt persönlich
überzeugen dass erstens die baustelle
dann los eingerichtet ist dass der
baufortschritt wie geplant ist und dass
alle leute höchst motiviert und super
toll bei der heute werden erste
fahrbahnplatten in die brücke
eingebracht danach erfolgt der
sogenannte anschieben der brücke auf das
fundament beim anschieben der brücke ist
besonders darauf zu achten dass die
gurte genau über die rollen kästen
aufsitzen und auflaufen
je besser man vermessen hat je genauer
funktioniert das ganze natürlich und die
schwierigkeit beim anschieben ist
eigentlich das koordinierte
zusammenwirken vom radlader mit der
manpowergroup meine aufgabe hier war es
die brücke zu vermessen und jetzt in der
schlussphase alles zu koordinieren
wir haben jetzt erste schub phase hinter
uns sind sechs felder wasserwerks
gefahren mit der brücke und sind somit
total im plansoll dass wir uns
vorgenommen haben
die brücke hat insgesamt 13 42 waren die
bauweise mit krippen gut wir haben eine
finale spannweite von 39 65 metern
die maximales gewicht der brücke selbst
hat 66,9 tonnen und kann mit 38 bahnen
im einzel nach befahren werden und wegen
der verpflegung der eingesetzten pionier
soldaten keine zeit zu verlieren wurde
diese kurzerhand an den ort des
geschehens verlegt die brücke soll
bereits übermorgen mittwoch an die
gemeinde übergeben werden können
befahrbar wird sie voraussichtlich ab
freitag sein